de multiples appels au calme ont été
lancés dans le monde le secrétaire
général des nations unies kofi annan
demande aux dirigeants palestiniens
israéliens de reprendre le contrôle de
la situation dans quelques instants vous
entendrez la réaction de madeleine
albright secrétaire d'état aux états
unis qui entretien enregistré ce matin
sur ce même plateau en france le
président de la république s'est dit
consterné très préoccupé le premier
missionnaire jospin a insisté pour que
l'engrenage de la violence s'arrête
toutes les deux ont fait des
déclarations publiques solennel
nous sommes
consternés
et très préoccupé par cette flambée de
violences
à l'origine jeudi dernier une
provocation irresponsable
sur le lieu sur le lieu saint de
l'esplanade des mosquées je souhaite
que chacun comprenne qu'on ne lutte pas
contre l'émotion d'un peuple avec des
blindés et qu'il faut engager un
processus où la raison retrouve toute sa
place je ne pense pas qu'ils aient une
provocation de la part d'israël je pense
que l'acte qu'a commis monsieur ariel
sharon en se rendant sur l'esplanade des
mosquées était un acte provocateur et
qui compte tenu de
tous les symboles qui s'attache à la
question de jérusalem qui est d'ailleurs
l'objet de discussions dans le cadre du
processus de paix
il y avait tout risque que cela provoque
des réactions en chaîne explosive